clearly the watch is a you know a device
it's going to be technology technology
driven but it also is going to be very
stylish and so it needs to be in that
world and appealing to people that buy
things for fashion yeah it's interesting
Mitchell what do you make of them taking
out this big ad in vogue of all places I
think it's a clear indication that it's
more about fashion than function you
know I think there have been reports
that the actual functionality has been
scaled back even from the original spec
and it looks like they're going to just
make this the must-have accessory yeah
so talking about this I mean is this
does this signal a bigger move for Apple
itself mean apples always been sort of
brand focused but I wonder if this is a
different take for them it is a bit of a
different take and it's it's Terranova
for them I think it is their first real
big for a since the ipad and you know
it's got to be a hit for them and
they're betting a lot on it so it's
pretty interesting that they're taking
this this fashion look at it Tim one of
the things I wonders if if Apple is
going to start to have a much more
segmented product line at much of
different price points is there any
suggestion what did you not know before
you saw these these ads well these has
just hit anything snow what well they
just hit on the things that we've seen
before the style of it all in aids more
about the placement in vogue they've
been on a cover of vogue in China
they've been doing things in Paris to
try to get into the fashion world and
there's some big questions that a lot of
people want to know in March when they
do this this event that we believe will
be about the watch and its pricing we
only know the base price it be 350 about
350 CC position as the key decisions
right right so then also we want to know
how long the battery's gonna last time
is this gonna be able to make it through
the whole day Tim Cook yesterday in
London telling newspaper there that he
wears it all day with the charge and it
goes now it was a lot of people looking
at that you know the other thing is you
know the case for why you're gonna want
this is it going to be just for style
ORS are gonna be functionality to it an
apple really hasn't laid out the entire
can use case for this point it's health
fitness that sort of thing but you know
why do you want to buy it Mitchell is
fashion enough to carry a brand to sell
the millions of watches that they're
gonna need to sell to make this business
work you know I think initially it will
be i think that apple has the kind of
panache that will make people go out and
a certain class of people the first
early adopters will go and buy it i
don't know if it's enough to carry it
long term I think it will have to have
some useful functions to really make it
a part of our day the way that so many
of their other devices have become and
would you expect to see more of these
ads in other places and what would that
tell you depending on where the
pyramidal yeah my guess is you're going
to see a lot more ads I think this
probably early indication tells you that
that is the way they're leaning I would
expect to see outdoor adds a lot of
print I wouldn't be surprised to see
some beautiful television pieces and you
know the thing is they're betting so
much on it every other major release
that they've had since the sieve jobs
era has been the must-have device and
and as you indicated this is a little
different so I think they have a lot
riding on